wer das Interview mit shelo und abti
gesehen hat der wird wissen wie sie auf
die Frage antworten wie steht er
eigentlich zur cannabislealisierung mich
wird übrigens ernsthaft interessieren
wie steht ihr dazu diskutiert es bitte
heftig in den Kommentaren und ansonsten
achtet auf das Ende dieses Community
Videos ich glaube ihr werdet es feiern
bis dann bleibt
dran ih hab 437 fragt verdient ihr genug
Geld mit der Musik um davon leben zu
können oder schuftet ihr nebenbei noch
ganz am Anfang zu
mitwagenzeit muss muss wir noch teils
teils
machen jetzt mittlerweile läuft ein
bisschen besser so eine Sache man hat so
geschafft wenn du so W du Geld für dich
hast und dein Eltern noch was trinken
kannst dann hast du so als Musiker so
geschafft den durchpruch so meine
Meinung Chris greenby will wissen wie
steht ihr zur Cannabis Legalisierung ich
bin dafür ich bin dafür ich sage ja
zabis
wer wer setzt sich noch mal dafür ein
die Grünen die Grünen ein und die
Piratenpartei aber die sind nicht
dingsfähig knon Styler chele und Abdi
meine Frage für euch wie wird man ein
aslac signing an ein asl siging kommt
man indem man gescoutet wird und wir
scouten Talente und ein Talent muss
zusätzlich dem Gesamtpaket entsprechen
alles es muss alles passen und wenn das
der Fall ist dann wirst du Einl sein du
musst einfach innovativ sein
fresh dein Style haben genau musst du
sein du musst du sein hallo ich wollte
nur mal fragen ob die vor stimmen dass
der Freestyle mit Haftbefehl vorher
schon ausgedacht war oder ob der
wirklich Freestyle war im klassischen
Sinne die haben falsch hingeschrieben
das die haben gesagt mach mal
Acapella einfach vor der Kamera das war
ein Acapella von schon geschriebenen
Text natürlich Freestyle Freestyle hören
wollt mal ein ab die Freestyle edinia
fragt wer zur Hölle sind die
ich der e alle ich bin ab
HipHop gib in
Youtube und ab ein und guck einfach und
genieß genießen anstatt zu schießen du
weißt na ich bin Haftbefehl werdet ihr
langsam Karl oder warum habt ihr Glatzen
es ist bequemer einfach du musst ganz du
musst keine Frisur machen so oder sowas
du gehst Duschen nimmst ein Handtuch und
dann kämpst du dich mit deinem Handtuch
kennst du das locker so fertig die
Frauen stehen auch drauf habe ich mal
von einem gesehen in Berlin der sagt
hast du mehr Zeit für Frauen und S sehen
der kümmert sich im Bad und Frisur jetzt
bei mir ist leider hier so kleine
landebasis und deswegen ist bei mir
total alles fresh und wenn nicht fresh
ist dann habe ich ein cy wie gesagt alle
Z D
Tage vi frisch vi frisch rasieren alles
rasiert alles rasiert rasieren schießen
Toastbrot L1 Frage lautet warum macht
ihr so schlechte Musik warum findest du
sie so schlecht wäre meine Gegenfrage
Toastbrot und warum ist Toastbrot jetzt
aber die Frage was empfindet Toastbrot
als gute Musik Butter Toast Butter
WAP es gibt auch Toast ohne Butter WP
Toast ohne Butter WP ich Kats der Mod
weg das war B belidig dann
Löcher the soul stes will wissen wo
bleibt eigentlich kon das K h ist das
unsere Frage an könnt
n
bist Big Boss Kolle sagt wie sie den
Fans ganz dreist anlügen die haben so
ein krasses Talent und verkacken durch
ihr gelüge mit HJ als wenn das im Juni
kommt hah ich glaube nichts mehr schon
dreimal rumgelogen also kann man ji wohl
auch nicht ernst nehmen ich kann die
Fans verstehen dass ihr abtör habt wie
gesagt beim legendären Allstars 4 hat ab
die gesagt 14 oktober hat leider nicht
so geklappt wie gesagt viel Schweiz und
so waren wir aber wir haben noch eins
Zeug gelegt
und geschafft 25 Mai haben wir es
geschafft zu realisieren das Release
Date wie gesagt jetzt kannst du es dir
vorbestellen bei amazon.de oder du gehst
in den Laden am 25 dir locker aber ich
habe noch nie meine Fans angelogen das
wie gesagt es passiert
mal dr dr D Detox ist schon so
dingsck wenn du Kombi holst irgendwo und
sagst ich bring dir morgen Kombi ohne
Zeitdruck genau das war's auch schon
danke fürs beantworten euer Haftbefehl
tschüss wer noch mehr sehen möchte mit
chelo und ab die sollte den Talk nicht
verpassen wo wir der Frage ganz
wissenschaftlich nachgegangen sind macht
Cannabis Konsum hungrig der Titel durch
den Rap haben wir die Kurve gekriegt und
auch eine interessante Kurve nimmt das
Community Video mit albagan wo er
nämlich verblüffenderweise erzählt dass
er sich inzwischen mit Bushido versöhnt
hat also eins von beiden anklicken auf
jeden Fall spannend lustig und
interessant und ansonsten bis dann bleib
dran tschüss macht's
gut
ciao
แ